- Good morning Believe Nation!
Today's message is keep moving forward.
Over to you, Johnny Depp.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- One of the greatest
pieces of advice I've ever
gotten in my life was from my mom.
When I was a little kid,
there was a kid who was
bugging me in school.
And she said, "Okay, I'm
going to tell you what to do."
She said, "The kid's bugging you,
"he puts his hands on you,
you pick up the nearest rock
"or whatever you can get your hands on,
"and you lay him out."
(audiences laughs)
- [Audience Member] Yay mom!
- Then I did.
(audience laughs loudly)
And I felt better.
And it worked.
(audience laughs)
So for me that was a great lesson because
someone had invaded my
space, invaded my being.
And was doing something
against me that I didn't
want to be done so I took
control of the situation
and I ran with it.
When years later after being
turned into a product
by a very huge corporation
that had their hands all over me
and I couldn't escape it.
I promised myself that I would
continue to move forward, and
do my best not to compromise
in any way, whatsoever.
Not allow anyone to put their hands on me
and affect me in that way.
So that's the best advise I
think I could give is just
to keep moving forward and
don't give a (bleep) what
anybody thinks, just keep moving forward
and what you have to do, for you.
- Starting a business is
going to be one of the hardest
things you ever do in your life.
You're going to come up
against challenges that you
never thought were possible.
Hardships that you never
imagined having to endure.
You have to keep moving forward.
You're going to have all
kinds of people in your life
tell you all the reasons why
it's not going to work out.
Why you can never do this.
And maybe you have that
voice inside your head
as well saying, "I can't do this."
You need to keep moving forward.
"But Evan you don't understand,
my situation is different.
"I didn't grow up with the
family that could help me.
"I didn't grow up with the resources.
"I didn't have the right education.
"I don't have the right connections.
"I don't have the financing to
get my dreams into reality."
You need to keep moving forward.
There will be times where
you will get hit so hard.
That you will feel so
terrible about yourself.
That you will bawl your face off.
That you will have the
lowest self-confidence ever
in your life because you're
pouring everything you have
into this idea and it's not working out
and you're not getting results.
You need to keep moving forward.
There's going to be times
when you look at yourself
in the mirror and you ask,
why am I doing this?
Is this worth the sacrifice?
Is this worth the pain?
Is this worth the struggle?
You better have a big dream.
And you need to keep moving forward.
Big things aren't created by
people who live their life
according to other people's expectations.
Big things are not created by
people who stop taking action
because they're afraid.
Big things aren't created by people who,
as soon as they come across
some adversity, they quit.
You need to keep moving forward.
Moving forward is hard.
It can suck.
It can take everything out of you.
But you owe it to yourself
to make this dream
that you have in your head come out.
Keep moving forward.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what are you
doing every single day
to keep moving forward?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Anil Grandhi.
Anil thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really really
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another
shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- Hey guys to stay on the theme of,
keep moving forward, I
thought I'd share a few
extra bonus clips to keep you motivated.
- Essentially, and I would
say this to anybody, is that
it's really, it's easy to
embrace hopelessness when
things seem insurmountable.
And yet, it's actually
just a matter of time
until all of the elements
come together for
things to be all right.
I believe that most difficult
situations will resolve
themselves if you are persistent
and if you don't,
if you don't give up entirely.
And that's what I never
did, I never gave up.
- Surely the opening vistas of space
promise high costs and hardships,
as well as high reward.
So it is not surprising
that some would have us
stay where we are a little longer,
to rest, to wait.
But this city of Houston,
this state of Texas,
this country of the United States
was not built by those
who waited and rested
and wished to look behind them.
(audience cheers and applauds)
This country was conquered
by those who moved forward
and so will space.
- Nothing in life worth having comes free.
Nobody's going to give anybody anything.
Now, you get out of life what
you're willing to put into it.
Hard work, sacrifice, dedication,
all of these things breed success.
Now, I can tell you this because,
I was once one of the people
who were assumed to be
less likely to become successful.
I'm from a very modest neighborhood.
(audience laughs)
I didn't necessarily grow up
with a silver spoon in my mouth.
I didn't have all the
things that I wanted.
Sometimes not even all
the things that I needed.
But, it's important for you to know,
your environment does not define you
unless you allow it to.
The position that you're in right now,
the position you're in right now
does not dictate your future
unless you allow it to.
You can look at your
life as it is right now,
you can look at it.
You can say,
"Well, I'm not where I
want to be, this isn't
"where my life will end."
You can do one of two things.
You can use it as an excuse to do nothing,
or you can use it as motivation
to push yourself forward.
The choice is yours.
I need you guys to
understand, and believe,
that anything in life is possible.
Whatever it is you want to
do, is absolutely possible.
I don't care how much trouble
you got into up until now.
I don't care how many things
you may have done wrong.
I don't care how much you
may not have in your life
to help you.
You can do it if you believe in yourself
enough to make it happen.
If you put enough...
If you put enough effort and energy,
and invest enough in your future,
you can do anything in
this world you want to do.
Anything's possible.
Don't never let nobody tell you,
what you can't do.
I started rapping when
I was nine years old.
Nine years old.
And I'm from Atlanta.
So at the time when I was rapping,
there wasn't no other rappers in Atlanta.
And I heard every excuse
why I couldn't be a rapper.
I heard every excuse why
I couldn't be famous.
Everything from,
"You can't rap., you're too skinny."
(audience laughs)
You know, everything from,
"Don't nobody from the South
make it big and go platinum."
I heard all these things,
a whole bunch of excuses,
a whole bunch of reasons why
I should not believe that I could make it.
But, my belief,
my belief overcame that doubt
because I believed in myself.
And if I can do it, whatever it is
that I have done, you can do it better.
- [Audience Member] Yep.
(students chuckle)
- All of you.